Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Flash episode 7 video.
Careful for spoilers if you haven't seen it
there were so many reveals probably the best
episode of the season so far, so here we go.
I was surprised by so many things in this
episode you know first that the big kiss they
haven't done that since season one in that
was every man that kissed her.
So for those asking yes this is something
from the comics but here listed top 10 WTF
because we had all the Savitar, the Doctor Alchemy stuff,
so here we go.
Number 10 the Flash versus Savitar. Just completely
takes him for ride He- I mean, he looks like a full-blown
transformer when they do like the full wide
shot of them but he takes Barry through what
looks like speed force portals like he's literally
running inside the speed force just popping
up all over town simultaneously or that's
the way it looks to Cisco and the other people.
So when he's running through this blue tunnel
here I think that's him running through the
speed force and at the end of the episode, you
know, number nine
He asks Alchemy to help him come back.
So here's where the writer of the episode did
a really good job of tying the storylines together
Wally West is stuck in this in between state
where his body can't really handle what's
going on to him.
I think that's what's also going on with
Savitar where he's kind of like half stuck inside
the speed force, so he's superfast he has white
lightning like that's how fast he is so he
have these crazy powers but he can't fully
manifest inside the world.
That's why he needs Alchemy's help to get
back so that is a bit of a twist on comic
book Savitar who did get stuck inside the
speed force but it was a little more straight
up like Wally West in the past defeats him
by trapping him inside the speed force but
then later he escapes and Barry Allen ends
up killing him accidentally.
So the story the TV show's going with is just
a little different trapped in the speed force
trying to get out a la Flash rebirth.
Geoff Johns not the new Flash rebirth.
But the old Flash rebirth. But number eight Caitlin's
powers are totally effective against him.
She can also leech energy, so that might come
in handy later too, but she just helps them
see him.
She also slows him down just a little bit.
So just remember that fight because those
skills will come in handy later because in
the comics the Flash was not able to defeat
Savitar without the help of other speedsters,
it's the same thing with Godspeed to so like
you have to have team Flash all working together
in order to defeat him and it sounds like that's
what they're kind of teasing for Savitar
like he's so hard-core.
There's no way Barry stands a chance without
the help of the rest of team Flash, so number
seven, though, as a consequence of helping him, Caitlin
starts to go full-blown Killer Frost. Only
the version they're going with on the TV show
is kind of in between like everybody's in
between- Wally is in between, Savitars in between,
Caitlin is halfway in between Killer Frost
and Caitlin Snow- so the way the producers
teased her is they said they were calling her
Caitlin Frost.
So she has the powers of Killer Frost, but
she still has the heart and the mind of Caitlin
Snow which is why she gets super scientific
when she's using her powers like she stabs
Barry in the exact right place that'll disable
him for four hours without killing him, but
the interrogation scene. so this was so great
number six Joe and Caitlin both go super
hard-core like Joe grabs him I just love his
version of him like last year when he clocked
Harrison wells like ain't takin' no shit Joe and
then later Caitlin is the exact same thing.
Maybe you should fear me now.
So number five.
She steals Julian and we see Greg Grunberg,
who's actually doing like a guest spot because
Kevin Smith is directing the episode.
Greg Grunberg also has done a lot of sci-fi
stuff like Star Trek, y'know, alias- a whole bunch
of sci-fi but he also has a TV show with Kevin
Smith called geeking out.
So I wonder if Kevin Smith asked them specially
to get Greg in the episode get him like a cameo,
but it was really fun seeing him.
So Caitlin takes Julian and you have like
the scientific version of Killer Frost asking
him to make an algorithm so they can track
down Alchemy using his followers.
This is why you clear your browser history
when you join a speed cult because they're
searching for people that have been searching
the Internet for Savitar, so let that be
a lesson to you. But number four full-blown
Killer Frost versus Vibe just like Cisco
saw in his vision surprise twist SnowBarry kiss
for all you shippers out there.
I was just blown away that they actually did
that but she does do it in the comics so it's
a comic book twist but you can laugh about
it because of what happened during season one
with Everyman they had that weird awkward
kiss.
This was way cooler because it got super comic
book-y Barry just goes super blue like that's
how cold he was.
So it was like a funny moment.
Just you know because of who they are.
But they also did it in a really cool, comic
book way, but then when my favorite Caitlin
scenes came right after this when she is just
super savage waking up in the pipeline she
just rips into all of them.
I just laughed so hard on how much she opened
up on them savage as hell.
But she also creates that huge rift with Cisco.
Now, they're playing it super ambiguous too
so yeah I mean Cisco and Barry will be friends
again.
But they just don't want it to automatically
go back to normal right away.
Same thing with number three Wally coming
out of the cocoon. So like I said one of the
themes of the episode was people being this
in between state are you good are you evil,
it's not a binary thing like Barry's speech
at the end so Wally comes out of the cocoon
and his body can't handle the changes, so
they have to go help him out but it also provides
this, y'know, really emotional scene with Caitlin
where she comes back from the brink because
she can't kill Barry.
So that's your answer to future Killer Frost
on the show were gonna see Caitlin Frost shall
probably lose her shit every once in a while
but just still be a core member of the team
she'll still be a series regular.
So she can be in most of the episodes in number
two now that she's kind of back to normal.
She's able to help them fix Wally.
So he has that really awesome sceneries running
around he's faster than Barry.
When Barry first had his accident that even
though it's all hopeful yet that really sad
moment with Julian where he makes Barry quit.
They even have like the Easter egg were he's
walking out and everything's really sad in
here that bolt of lightning just making you
remember when he first got his powers.
So never fear I totally think that he will
be back in that lab before the end of the
season but big twist number one Julian is
revealed as Doctor Alchemy in the maybe not
surprising twist I think a lot of people were
expecting it because Julian Albert Albert
Desmond Doctor Alchemy the second version
of the character worked in the CSI lab with
Barry.
So like there were a couple clues pointing
to him possibly being Alchemy but the real
question now is how aware of Alchemy is Julian
is it like a split personality situation or
is it like Caitlin where like her brain just
goes a little bit nuts when she's in Killer
Frost mode, so she's not thinking clearly.
You know we don't know how much Julian is
complicit with Doctor Alchemy like is is a
cost plays situation or is it straight up
split personalities like it was in the comics
but we had to talk about's Savitar like there's
so much going on here.
So like he has that crazy mouth like when
he opens up that I still think that it's a
person underneath there somewhere he says
he's the future you're the past, the acolyte
said that he showed them all the future, I
saw you it was glorious you are Killer Frost.
So if is Savitar from the future like did
he come from the future to the past, to try
and take over or is he somebody from the present
who has seen the future because he got speed
force powers and is trying like bring about
this future outcome there is actually a new
52 future Flash storyline where future Flash
Barry Allen comes back to kill himself in
the past to prevent a bunch of bad stuff from
happening.
This doesn't seem like that but I might do
like a separate video for future Flash to
explain that, because it is an interesting
twist like the reverse Flash is also a time
traveler who came back in the past, to try
and change the future, so whatever's happened's
Savitar is trapped in like this in between
state but he has all this power and needs
Alchemy to help bring him back fully.
So the real thing now is in figuring out what
Julian is going to do about Doctor Alchemy
and what's Savitar's real plan is like what
is actually going to do to bring himself back
so's a great character episode great twist
comic book episode like rate WTF moment big
action set piece episode two, so I feel like
the script was better the action was better
the characters were better.
So hands down favorite episode this season
so far will see if the four way crossover
or the midseason finale can top it.
It's going to be really hard to top let me
know what was your favorite moment was this
your favorite episode of the season so far.
It was fun with all the Flashpoint stuff in
the beginning and you can kind of tell they
wanted to slowly weave's Savitar and he was
there from the beginning like he killed the
rival at the end of episode two, so he's always
been around, but they really wanted to establish
the new speedsters like Jesse Quick Wally
West like explain those concepts of the people
understood tease out Doctor Alchemy.
So he seems like a really big deal in even
like the big twist with the rival to like
look at this big boss who doesn't matter at
all because we kill them off in the second
episode that was a really fun twist where
you have like the super evil guy come kill
the other person that you think is supposed
to be the main villain just to show you how
bad as he is, but a lot of you might have
noticed that's Savitar's voice still sounds
like Tobin Bell.
So when we hear Alchemy speak and we think
it's Tobin Bell maybe somehow he's replicating's
Savitar's voice, but for those you asking
yes that is Tobin Bell who is speaking will
hear's Savitar speaking.
So the only other really big Easter eggs that
I spotted in the episode was the Game of Thrones
shout don't go all mother dragons on me with
the hair when Cisco was talking to Caitlin
that the Wally thing with him being faster
than Barry was the beginning is also comic
book thing because comic book Wally West was
the fastest version of the Flash so we'll
see how fast Wally gets eventually but this
is like just the beginning for his character
and when HR says Barry's superpower is hope
that's also a comic book thing Barry even
became a part of the Blue Lantern Corps which
harnessed the blue light of hope during the
war of the light.
So really cool nod to that but also probably
the smartest thing that ever come out of that
HR characters mouth.
So despite not being a scientist he actually
does have some emotional intelligence and
him somewhere in I'm really curious to see
if we ever see Caitlin put on some kind of
comic book looking costume.
Because they made that but they only use it
in the Flash for like the potential future
where she's fighting Cisco as full-blown Killer
Frost really important stuff though.
Next week is the big four night crossover
it's gonna be purely dominators.
But they might lightly touch on this Doctor
Alchemy's Savitar stuff so I'll say congratulations
to this week's DC giveaway winner David Grace
you and a $20 Amazon gift card be sure to
private message me on the back and my channel
so I can get your contact details.
There is a new round that starts now I'm just
going to start a new round now and if you'd
like any special bonus videos on Killer Frost
or any other concepts like future Flash just
let me know in the comments because a lot
of really cool, comic book stuff happening,
but the TV show as it tends to do is mixing
and matching things.
there is like a bunch of comic book stuff
happening tomorrow.
There's no new episode of Arrow but Kevin
Feige did this big Marvel vs DC explainer
where he was talking about the Marvel films
they been making what DC is doing and why
they're probably not going to be able to make
a deal with Fox anytime soon for the X-Men
characters so I'll do a video for that next,
but there's also been some talk of Carnage
showing up in the Spider-Man Marvel movies
so I'll do a video for that too and then obviously
we got some new footage for the big four night
crossover so whole bunch of Marvel and DC
posting I'll try to get that out as fast as
possible while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my Godspeed vs Savitar
video and you can click here for the Trailer
for the big 4 night crossover, thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight!